was because of me my friend sent me a
link to a video posted on that site
Intelligentsia the one for hateful
babies yep
ungrateful man babies
it sounds what Intelligence on the
websites are you kidding me
it's so much more than a website Mt it's
a communal experience
they're hateful man babies go
intelligence is literally a website it's
literally Reddit I love it this is just
Reddit wow
it's Reddit a bit of 4chan a bit uh what
is a Hitler a bit of new rock stars
comment section yeah the dark web it's
not just Charles every troll Forum on
the Internet is backed by something
is this also backed by Jeff Bezos he's
ever he's like uh 40 of these accounts
he said he said get rid of [ __ ] Hulk
this is
oh they're back
they're being somebody's punching me
okay oh he has a signature for his text
messages
yeah he does it's like my mom texted me
oh my god oh that's not that is awesome
tranquilizers yeah what is that for oh
that's for her so okay so intelligencia
is not just a website it is so much more
okay let's go let's go
I'm telling you behind every uh uh toxic
Reddit uh subreddit is um a lab trying
to steal our blood I think that's what
this proves I'm trying to steal my blood
hey lab if you want my blood just ask me
for it you can borrow oh yeah yeah for
sure I mean I have blood I'm lousy with
blood I notice you have vials of blood
on your floor you're always stepping
through it to get to your computer chair
I am it's like an Indiana Jones through
the uh through the temple because you
know I I like to give myself a challenge
right it's Monday I'll I'll Domino these
over you know me the most beautiful
thing it's seven things welcome back to
New rockstars everybody She-Hulk episode
6 goes full bridesmaids but also
introduces to the MCU the Intelligentsia
in the comics an Eclectic group of evil
brainiacs button She-Hulk it seems a
website in the vein of Reddit Fortune
maybe a bit of parlor splashed in there
uh meaning defeating the leader in
Captain America 4 will be as easy as
unplugging his router holy [ __ ]
this is inside Marvel it's new rock
stars She-Hulk after show America boss
with me is Jessica Clemens and Mt
welcome my friends dude I am so happy to
finally see the Intelligentsia pop back
up vmcu this is so cool I'm so excited
yeah and I I'm super excited too this
episode I was a little worried at the
beginning where she just kind of turned
to camera and said it's gonna be a
self-contained wedding episode because
my response would be like a lot of these
episodes have been just like
self-contained something episodes to now
how is this breaking the trend that you
tend to season a shield but it turns out
now it's a red herring because this
episode was probably the biggest Leap
Forward in terms of what this series is
trying to do uh we finally get a sense
of who is behind all of this evil doing
oh and Jen's life what the real conflict
is and it turns out it is the
intelligents yeah a very important
entity in the Marvel Comics and uh while
the intelligencies seems to be using the
front of a troll website as an
information resource the true operation
is something far more Sinister and far
more Hands-On a whole Lab spying on
She-Hulk in times where there should not
be cameras lying around and they're
trying to analyze their blood acquire
more blood designing new scary needles
to steal more blood uh I mean General
thoughts this episode how are you guys
feeling about this season I love the
season as a whole this episode did feel
like a fluffer episode but I think she
said that at the beginning so I was like
oh I'm not caught off guard uh Jessica
are you using the Hollywood industry
definition of fluffer because that is a
very different definition oh I think
they were just massaging
I'm a Zeus episode they were folding in
the cheese but no I did like uh once
once it got to the part uh once it got
to that part there's also I just I love
them uh Mr Immortal the entire oh my God
yes she's very good oh my God also they
did not need to make him so attractive
because then I was like I was like yeah
he would have got me he would have got
me I would have been one of those wives
yeah he would have took all my savings
and ran away and then I would just
assumed he's dead or even after you saw
that you would have been like I'll still
marry you I can I can fix it
he's been alive forever and I can change
he's older than Christ
but no I I also really like this uh
season this episode was really fun I
just I liked seeing seeing Jen like
continue her struggles with like you
know being compared to She-Hulk and like
how just Jen doesn't feel like enough
for some people so like I like seeing
that yeah let's recap what we saw this
episode just to remind ourselves so Jen
gets invited last minute to be
bridesmaid to the wedding of her friend
Lulu played by the hilarious Patty
Harrison Patty Harrison is one of my in
one of my favorite I think you should
leave sketches and uh if you haven't
seen that series on Netflix check it out
it there's like a shark tank parody
where she plays someone who made all
she's like one of the judges who made
all of her billions from suing the city
of New York for getting sewn into the
pants is it the Charlie Brown balloon is
this in the second season I think it's
season two okay I was like my favorite
in the first season where she's like
Santa came early
I love her so she's great I want to know
what Lulu's deal is like who I don't
think we saw who she was marrying and
did she really want Jen there because
she seemed pretty mean to Jen but then
was she just too drunk not to care I
think time will tell I I think that
there may be some duplicitous motives
behind Lulu because it was a whole last
minute invitation right like it seemed
like she got this box and then a day
later she was packing up to go to this
way it was so confusing because it was
like I I at first you're like oh she's
inviting her because she's she-hulked
and she's like don't turn into She-Hulk
because it's going to take away from me
and then at the end she's like oh she
hulks at my wedding I can't be happier
and it's just such a Patty Harrison
that's her comedy and her face that I
can't read it I literally couldn't I was
like is she actually happy or is she
just drunk and I was like that's just
Patty Harrison's comedy and so I'm so
confused I would say it's absurd to uh
invites have enough money to pay for one
of these elaborate will you be my
bridesmaid boxes but then have a cash
bar at the wedding like how much what is
your budget for this one but I've been
to so many weddings where like why did
you spend so much money on this but then
not on this like why are there why is
there no food at this wedding but there
is like a one of those Sparkle showers
at this wedding like we're at a concert
uh there's like it's insane I will stay
at the wedding we had uh there's no
[ __ ] way we're gonna have a cash bar
to our wedding with our families are you
are you kidding me that was like the
first thing must have an open bar at the
sweating there's no way no way we would
have gotten by but I just I found that a
bit of funny a wedding commentary uh I
guess I should say like I asked someone
to fill in as a groomsman with like with
a week's notice but I kind of knew um a
couple months ahead of time that there
was one group so we might not be able to
make it so I went on Craigslist for my
groomsmen just kidding I'm too single
that's the joke
of the Single part that wedding the
wedding in the episode was a not trying
to be mean but a little cheap it was a
little cheap it was very small there was
no food and also how are you gonna do
all the partying before the bride shows
up it's serious right it's all weird it
was all weird it all looked staged a
little bit right it was kind of just
kind of fit the narrative beats that
they want to tell the episode but it
wasn't like you know in a true rom-com
fashion where like the story does fit in
with the actual time of the episode or
of a thing like Bridesmaids right that
whole uh thing like they follow the the
normal order of it in terms of even how
absurd a wedding can be I was even
thinking like crazy Rich Asians a movie
that I very much enjoy I love crazy Rich
Asians who doesn't uh and I was thinking
about that wedding scene in Crazy rich
Asian oh the woman with the water with
the little streams
so like don't see it for that scene
every time I watch that scene I love
that scene she takes off her shoes she
walks down the eye on the wall okay
we'll get back onto that
so this episode kind of opens with after
she gets this invite Jen turns to camera
and announces that this will be a
self-contained wedding episode it says
if you think this is taking place An
Inconvenient time this season you're
right now ultimately this was a very
eventful episode you know but I think
this Series has just this recurring move
of using Jen's breaking the fourth wall
to kind of get ahead of any criticism
and in screenwriting a term for this is
called hanging the lantern when there's
just some kind of like shortcut that you
take narratively or some kind of cliche
or Trope that you know isn't like the
like the move that you wish you would
have made you just kind of hang a
lantern on you have a character call it
out in context and it shows the audience
that like don't worry I'm aware of this
trust me on this we'll get to it on the
other side but like so far in She-Hulk
it doesn't seem like they are really
writing beyond that they're just kind of
calling it out saying nope this is part
of the world where the character is
going to make fun of yourself but it's
like at this point you're making fun of
your own shortcuts and you don't really
prove on the other side of it that the
shortcut was worth it you're just kind
of I know this is just a little gripe
that I had I think ultimately the show
is working fine it's I'm enjoying it
enough but I'm just like you don't need
to have her call out your own weaknesses
because I think a lot of viewers
wouldn't even recognize these as
shortcuts or tropes before you called it
out it's interesting I think we notice
it because we're in entertainment
yeah we went to school for it because
I'm like there's probably someone that
needs it written out for them like even
you explaining the hangman Lantern
there's people out there that don't know
what that means sure sure yeah I don't
think I don't expect the general viewer
to understand hanging the lantern but I
think the general viewer does have kind
of like a subconscious reaction to when
something feels a little cliche or
something feels a little like uh too
much of a subversion of expectation and
I think this was this line was because
last episode ended with like a tease of
Daredevil and I think it was basically
saying like you're not going to see
Daredevil this episode basically I think
that's what it was all about yeah I feel
like um the writers of the show realize
like how like how much of like an uphill
Journey they have in terms of like
pleasing like the audience because like
a lot of female lead shows get met with
a lot of criticism like for no reason
and so like I feel like they have she
helped me like all right prepare
yourself this is my show all right so
this is a lawyer show don't like Wong is
here but this is a lawyer show like I
feel like they're preparing them
preparing like the toxic male's reaction
because like they see it they they know
it's coming they saw it when she elk was
announced so they were just like you
know what let's just write this into the
show to sort of like calm these be this
specific audience
um but that's just my weird assessment
no I agree she's done it now this is the
third time because in the first episode
she was like I know you're not ready for
this lawyer show and I'm Gonna Give You
backstory and then the third episode she
was like this isn't a long episode Wong
and Bruce and them aren't going to be in
every season or every episode just get
that in your mind so I think they're
just like yeah just setting it setting
it up so people can't knock them down
before they knock themselves down I
guess yeah I think they're just trying
to get ahead of it I just think it's
interesting that they're doing that like
I think overall it seems to be
successful uh and it and I I do like
that it is rooted in who She-Hulk is
like that is something that she's always
kind of like been doing in the comics
he's talked to the audience
um this show has like a really
unprecedented relationship with the
marble audience that a lot of other
really any other Marvel MCU property has
up until this point like a character
talking directly audience is something
that like is completely new I I I'm not
convinced yet that the writers of the
show understand the full power of that
because that is such a powerful thing to
like remember in 2016 with Deadpool it
seemed like Ryan Reynolds fully
understand who his audience was and
exactly who he was talking to I think
there are times where like I'm watching
the show and Jen is talking to camera
and I kind of look around the room I'm
like who what audience right now is Jen
talking to because I think a lot of
people watching right now are not really
connecting with what she's saying that's
what I like about it because it's giving
me Wanda Vision where it's like it's for
everybody rather than it's just for one
group of people so it's like when she's
talking to us she's talking to us more
so that it's a lawyer show than it is
about she-hole which I understand it's
like how are you going to be a Marvel
show in a Disney Plus show and not be
more Marvel than a lawyer show but I
think that's what they're trying to get
at is like we'll still have those like
Marvel under tones but we're really like
this is for everybody we want to make
sure everyone feels involved in this so
I think that's why it's like because I
was getting that too I was like this is
a conversation for the girls like this
sometimes where I'm like this is just
between me and you I don't know if any
other virusing can listen to this but I
get what you're saying which I'm happy
to be I'm happy to be looped in on
because you know
so what are they what are they talking
about what are they talking about oh
[Music]
it's a very fun spot yeah and I am
having a lot of fun I really do like
just exploring the legal side of this
world Jesus I think it's just really fun
to the the intersection between
superhero characters and like the law I
think is endlessly fascinating on this
show I love doing the breakdowns I love
doing the breakdowns
I don't know law and I've had to read so
many like PDF like I've had to download
full law books and go to my lawyer
friend and be like can you please
explain this I was like I don't know how
law works you know what we need is we
need to get that legal eagle guy and
just make him part of the new rockstars
team so we can have a whole separate uh
like just separate analysis it's just
like a legal breakdown of an episode of
new rock stars just to get in an ex like
someone with a jurisdiction I went I
researched and I go in on if you're
resurrected does your marriage get
annulled or not so just wait for wait
for that whether or not it's legal to
marry a dead person I love that
um yeah so the Beast story this episode
explores all this stuff Nikki and
Mallory are teaming up to take the case
of Mr Immortal Craig Hollis uh Mr mortal
is it recurring character in Marvel
Comics I'm surprised that like they
introduced him in this way on She-Hulk
uh he's in titles like West Coast
Avenger Great Lakes Avengers he has a
friendship with the cosmic entity entity
the death urge as he calls him the dirge
or dirge uh but he's played by our man
Dave pascuasi aka the twilik major Domo
from Boba Fett and one of my favorite
Chicago improvisers part of the duo TJ
and Dave I love this guy he's so funny
in this and he wants GLK and H to help
him with his divorce cases several
ex-spouses who want him to pay up uh
because he has uh he's trying to kill
himself and invent a new identity just
to get out of a marriage and these are
the ones who are just still alive we
gotta imagine this guy's been doing this
for seven years
I love it it's so funny
so funny
so easy to just go into the comics and
find like Mr Immortal and make him a
comedy bit a man that literally Never
Dies how can you make him into like
literally the definition of like a boy
like how can you know and they did and
say run from your problems jump out of
the window
there's also a line in the episode where
he straight up is like I'll never
understand women not even when I'm oh
well I will be and he's talking about
like his age how he's never gonna like
he's like I'll never know them even when
I'm a thousand well I am going to be a
thousand so maybe I will and I'm like
Jesus right he's so good the actor is
also amazing oh I'm obsessed yeah uh uh
so one of these Ex-Wives mentions a
website called Intelligentsia they
posted Craig's attempt to walk into
traffic and pick his death uh Craig
agrees to split his wealth with these
exes and Nikki helps each of them reach
an agreement over how much each uh
deserve of his wealth and what do you
say his wealth was from uh the the baron
uh this is like a real person yeah it's
like it's King Henry's like a
sister-in-law
[Laughter]
Cromwell but I think he's talking about
King Henry's sister-in-law his third
wife's sister and he bought stock and
apple in 1981 which is just like smart
stock purchasing Mr mortal doesn't have
knowledge of the future he's just
playing bought stock at the right time
if like when they make the Eternal
sequel I want to see Mr Immortal and
they're like come on come on or
something
um so we see this wedding uh where
Janice is treated horribly you know uh
Titania shows up we realize her the
person she's walking down the aisle with
Jonathan is just a sick dog and uh they
make her they like put her to work at
this wedding she meets a cute guy named
Josh though this wedding is a cash bar
but the DJ is DJ in cheddable home hits
us with some Annie Linux so you know
it's not all that bad I love Chad he's
so funny yep one of the interesting
wedding song of uh walking on broken
glass it plays at a lot of weddings
didn't all play at your wedding did not
play at our wedding but we didn't have a
lot of time to dance at our wedding we
had maybe I don't know hour 15 minutes
that was not a lot of time but that song
plays at a lot of weddings I don't
really dance to it because it's hard to
dance to as you see Jen do in the
episode it's really hard to get Rhythm
to that song but Tatiana maslani just
kind of like does her thing and like I
don't know if we saw a video this but
someone definitely tweeted right when
she look was coming out they're like
here's my personal story about touching
on my slani I was at like some press
party after an award show or Emmys after
the Golden Globes and it's one of these
things where like no one is dancing
everyone just kind of moved on to a
different party or whatever but they
have a dance floor with a DJ and I look
over it's just Tatiana maslani buy
herself on the Dance Floor Just shoes
off just like dancing on her own just
having a blast and I feel like this is
just they let her do her thing here like
it felt so it's so funny she is the
funniest act like I just want to like an
angel hang out with her just regularly
just be besties like she seems so fun
she seems like a great person I'm a big
fan of her I love what she's doing on
this show like she's just like settled
into this part so well and I just said
I'm having a lot of fun watching her and
Jen tries to drunk dial Bruce but he
isn't picking up maybe because he's like
he just knows that she's drunk he's like
this time I won't have a conversation
about this and Jen get she throws up
gets sucker punched by Titania which
feels like a dick move right like major
she's not even standing up and why why
are you punching her you know what if
you're not uh always keeping one eye
open
this is me trying to defend Titans
I love Titania and I was I love that
scene of her being like Oh it's okay get
it out I was like yeah
I gotta say this moment made me like
titanium less not just because she
sucker punches her but like I didn't
really understand her motivation she's
like you need to Hulk out so I can fight
you because I'm jealous and you have all
this and you don't deserve it or you
don't even want it but then I wanna I
wanna know where did your powers come
from like who are you like are you is
this something given to you do is it
naturally for me where are you coming
from I am upset that we it's episode six
and we still don't know why she broke
into the courtroom exactly like that is
the biggest question trying to figure
that out and so but I and I don't like
that we have to theorize because I
immediately went to oh she's publicly
humiliated because of She-Hulk so she's
trying to like redeem herself even if
it's in front of people that's like I'm
actually better than you you suck and
I'm like but I don't like to have to
theorize that I want you guys to have to
give it to me like a justification it
and that's why I'm like maybe we'll get
that justification when we know who sent
her to the courtroom but we don't know
yet why is she not in prison right I
know just for that alone why is she not
in prison but you're you're both very
right like this is it's one thing to
have the intelligencia left a mystery
right if you're gonna do this thing that
they do on pretty much all these series
have like the the big boss behind the
shot behind the curtain uh but to have
just another character he seems like an
independent actor and we still have no
idea what they're all about and but they
seem to be so important to the story
like like I I think looking back on the
past couple Marvel titles I think it's
actually kind of refreshing that Moon
Knight told us basically who the villain
was in the opening scene and then never
really wavered from that and really the
mystery was how much of uh of Stephen
Grant's worlds is real or not yeah and
the conflict almost wasn't really with
uh Arthur Hero on that show and similar
with uh Ms Marvel is like we met the
clandestines in episode three and then
like by episode like by the end of that
episode we knew that they were bad guys
uh so like I kind of liked that we
didn't have this whole mystery of who
the villain is we don't need that in
every title I'm not trying to sound
horrible when I say this but I think
it's because Moon Knight and Miss Marvel
had something to lose
um if I when I say that I mean like
those were two shows that were dropping
that people weren't so sure about they
don't know that much about the character
behind the scenes so it's like we need
to make sure that this script is
foolproof that like when we give them is
good to go with that one season where
She-Hulk it's like she's still Bruce
Banner's cousin and we know who she Hulk
is kind of so it's like she's gonna
we're gonna see her again we know we're
gonna see her again but there was a
chance we might not see Moon Knight as
much or Miss Marvel and so I think
they're like we had to double down on
this script versus this one yeah not not
to shame the writers for shield I love
She-Hulk it's just that you you
recognize which one is gonna get wavy no
I think you're totally right I hear what
you're saying Jess and I think part of
it is just like the format they're going
for they're going for more of an
episodic thing where each episode does
feel a bit more self-contained and uh in
that you uh can have a bit lower Stakes
the shows that they're they're modeling
on and just have lower Stakes yeah
whereas like Moon Knight and Miss Marvel
we're we're truly trying to do like two
and a half hour movies or two hour
movies with those with those stories and
you know we didn't know you're yeah
that's a very good point I didn't think
about that but uh okay so these two
fight I do like that we get to see Jen
do the Hulk stomp attack that was fun
Titania slips and busts up her veneers
just by slipping on ice
um and then this episode ends with Mal
and Nicki investigating the
intelligencies site comes off as the
typical kind of Reddit 4chan Forum it's
run by a mod named Hulk King at first
time to do a double take I'm like does
that say hulkling no it says Hulk King
uh and they create an account and access
a forum dedicated to hate posts and
death threats to She-Hulk and as Jen
eats fries with Josh finally gets her
man to eat some fries with right that's
what we're all looking for just someone
to split surprise with uh and then she
gets to end up watch she's being watched
by a computer interface at this wedding
meaning there's like a camera set up
somewhere in a bush there or at the bar
in the ice bucket in the tip jar
wherever
um and it this transition is crazy it's
like a weird kind of like uh ultroni
types uh transition through the through
the screen and Hulk King is using his
same kind of messaging app to pop up on
the screen asking about next steps of
the plan uh and we see some unseen
scientists readying needles similar to
the bent needle that The Wrecking Crew
had a couple episodes back so we know
The Wrecking Crew is part of this
operation uh but they prepare a much
larger sturdier needle and close it into
a case so we're going to talk about this
group The intelligencia and trust us
they're not as lame as they initially
come off in this episode uh remember the
Mandarin ladies and gentlemen those uh
these fools I believe are the court
Jesters of the true Marvel intelligencia
the way Mandarin was as we learned in
changing I think all right we'll see Mt
hit us with that merch plug guys be sure
to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to grab our latest
Obsession shirt Lady Justice inspired by
the very She-Hulk show that we are
talking about right now the shirt is
limited editions and when you purchase
it you unlock the ability to get a
custom shout out that will appear right
here on inside Marvels support the
channel and check out all of our awesome
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com today great uh and
okay so what are we talking about this
episode what is the Intelligentsia for
real who are they what are they what's
the what's the big deal
wait a minute who are they it's Marvel's
intelligencia was considered a
collective of villains a simple to
exchange information among Evil Geniuses
specifically their first need was to
share Knowledge from the Library of
Alexandria there's a whole plot
revolving around that it was kind of the
branch out of the leader who reached out
to the wizard and then Egghead the Mad
thinker Red Ghost this team ended up
being thwarted by Doctor Doom who's like
I go to keep all this knowledge F off uh
but then years later the team gets
reformulated by Modoc in the leader and
they set their sights on Hulk their plot
really is to like have a Hulk that they
can control because if you think about
it it's kind of the ultimate uncontained
uh chaos power uh at least when it comes
to Raw physical power uh they end up
unleashing Red Hulk on the world in an
attempt to control Red Hulk I I'm
summarizing there's a lot of cool beats
I highly recommend you read the comics
this is fairly recent it was really from
like what 13 years ago 14 years ago when
all these were coming out oh recent yeah
red Hulk turns on them and they get what
say like some of these Like eternals
Comics you know those Comics that we all
read in 1970 dub
no no unready Turtles comics as a kid I
guarantee you the the only people who
writing Turtles comics work at Marvel we
can talk about this another time because
if there is a comic when I was young I
looked up hot comic book characters and
then I read them and eternals was one of
them because everybody's internals is
hot
yes the the Neil Gaiman eternals run in
the 90s was a very popular run a lot of
people read it and it was very very good
I I at least was I didn't hadn't read it
until they announced the eternals movie
but I was like aware of that name
somewhere but I was just like that looks
stupid I don't care how to do that and
then the Neil Gaiman run was that that's
a actually really really good storyline
I wish I had read it but I'm talking
about the original 70s uh eternals no
one read those no except Neil Gaiman
read them and he's like there's a better
version of this story
um there's like one 55 year old
commenter who's like I read it I had the
first issue I stood in line how do you
think 55 year old people talking to
their old Prospectors
not old
my great-grandson had that book read to
him just last night by me would you like
a Tootsie Pop they were literally bored
in like 69 not even they were born at
like 72.
the Intelligentsia they end up getting
kind of thwarted by Red Hulk who turns
on them Amadeus show Hulk helps take
them down uh but we've been speculating
the MC would bring in the intelligencia
soon probably in this series even the
way things have been going they really
are the go-to super villain Network when
it comes to uh like who's trying to
control Hulk from behind the scenes it
makes sense that they would be the
bosses Behind The Wrecking Crew who
tried to steal Jen's blood earlier this
season and Marvel did just announce the
leader is returning it to the MCU in
Captain America new world to order and
that title of that movie is suggesting
it's going to focus on conspiracy
theories misinformation which kind of
seems like the kind of content you would
imagine seeing on the intelligencia
website and quantumania it's confirmed
to introduce some form of Modoc we're
not sure yet which looks like a robotic
form of Modoc but we don't really know
it's just a quick shot in the d23
footage so uh this episode of She-Hulk
at first reveals the intelligency to be
like just as the [ __ ] posty website for
in sales trolls and the like but I think
there's obviously more to it than that
because it's modded by a user named Hulk
King I think we can safely say that will
probably be Todd right Todd was just too
big of an actor to play a one-off role
of Jen's date who then showed up in the
courtroom he did show up as this client
at glkh he clearly has a little bit more
wealth and influence than seen before he
seems like the kind of guy who would be
the the owner of this website I think
he's a nerd who created this site and
then that site might have been acquired
by a large organization who uses this
site many other sites as part of their
Sinister information gathering scheme to
data mind people servers spy on as many
people as possible and also to just like
crowdsource as many anecdotal rumors as
possible as to what gen's weaknesses
might be if you imagine you know
Facebook
meta is like buying Instagram and all
these other websites I think he's kind
of the Zuckerberg figure behind it but
someone who's not as a public-facing
owner of it I think ultimately it's
pretty clear they want Hulk blood or
she-hulk's blood they want to create
their own Hulk and I think it's going to
be either Red Hulk or some other kind of
additional Hulk some kind of new player
I think that's what's going to be coming
at the end of the series now will they
have the budget for it I don't know
because all the other uh shots of Jen
hulking out they keep cutting away from
it they so rarely show her fully hulking
out I don't think we've ever seen just a
complete on-screen framed in mid uh
hulking out shot they keep cutting from
her point of view or something and it's
like yikes so what are they saving the
money for on the show or or are they
showing us that expensive I think it's a
ladder honestly I don't think Red Hulk
is coming in because of that reason only
okay okay but do you think I think some
other Hulk is coming I think Bruce is
going to return to stop it I think
Blonsky is going to team up with them to
redeem himself I think we're gonna get a
Hulk versus Hulk battle and I think
that's going to shut up all the haters
at the end of the season because I think
just a multiple hulks kind of in a melee
just imagine that like that could be
freaking wild so that's just where I
think this is all headed right now uh I
want to ask your thoughts but I also
want to ask you guys about like what's
going on at this wedding do you think
this wedding was all a sham that camera
was it set up on Jen and Josh in that
final scene by people like was Lulu paid
to set up this thing was she trying to
get Jen's DNA is that why she told her
to de-power initially is that why she
really invited Titania to knock her out
can we even trust her boy Josh who's
snacking on those fries with her because
right now this Series has told me not to
trust any of the men who's interested in
jail it's like a I guess he's a Sonic
too yeah the second Sonic movie like
that whole wedding was a sham for just
to get like Sonic like I feel like that
again it would be hilarious that's what
I was a piece of me was thinking that
when I was riding the breakdown I was
like what if this entire wedding's a
sham that's why we don't really see Adam
the husband and that's why we don't
really like they hired shed to DJ and
he's doing bad
no DJ has an actual blow horn and
there's not that many people there like
it just looks so disheveled that I was
starting to believe that it was a sham
but I I don't wanna I really don't want
to believe it but I know Josh is a sham
I know Josh isn't yeah Josh is like but
too good to be true like too too
attractive like all right hey what's
going on Jen specifically I think I am
really digging you I think the website
is also to just like not only throw up
threats to kill She-Hulk but just also
like yeah I went on a date with She-Hulk
and she said she didn't like me because
I talked too much she didn't like me
because I didn't oh hold the door for
her and so they're using those pieces of
knowledge to create what is Josh and
Josh is the opposite of those guys so
he's gonna be the only one that can
really uh Trojan Horse himself into that
I love it this is what uh this is what
men do on websites they go to like am I
the [ __ ] on Reddit just to like learn
a list of what not to do just follow
this list of rules I'll be the perfect
date it's a joke you are joking but I
know damn well there is I know there's a
man that was like oh so I shouldn't
throw away my wife's prize possessions
they're definitely
you mean women like when you listen
[Laughter]
I don't know I'll try my one
I'll try I'll try when I'll get back to
everybody on this site
but I do think Josh is definitely a
trojan horse is a scam I don't think
it's good and also it's like they're
giving us too much knowledge about
Daredevil and her and I I don't want to
[ __ ] people immediately but I'm like I I
think once you put two men that are
interested one's gotta be bad and one's
gotta be good I think that's what's
gonna look a good point yeah I mean the
they had fries like this was like an
event space that probably was catered
for your wedding or maybe the food
wasn't that good you think they got a
deep fryer back there they don't serve
fries at a wedding
you can't cater fries where do you think
they got the fries
that didn't look like do you think they
Uber eat yeah
those were steak fries and a plate of
fries where in that bar and event space
did they get a fryer our department boss
here our department boss here to make
his quarrels right now the airfryers
the only reason I mentioned is that my
wedding you know you try to do your late
night snack we're gonna do a late one
and we ubered in some White Castle just
as like a nice little late night snack
for I guess and like that's how you get
but we also got married in the middle of
Chicago where there are fast food
restaurants everywhere like we could do
that this was in like some Northern
California this was some Thousand Oaks
Barn you know we've been invited to a
few of these weddings Jess you know how
these weddings go they're out kind of in
the middle of nowhere yeah I've been to
this exact wedding before too the food
they don't have fries I will die on this
hill where do they get the fries I think
it's okay to die on this hill I agree
with you I think it's ridiculous I think
it's a made-up thing
but now back to this uh the whole King
bit and like I like how you um
no I really like how you uh you brought
out the Red Hulk because the
intelligentia did make the Red Hulk in
the comics and uh unfortunately with the
passing of um I'm flaking on his name
I'm so sorry a thunderbolt Ross
um we can't really do that whole route
but I think that Todd and I made a video
about this before I honestly feel like
Todd is playing madman who is a Hulk in
the comics but he's also red which would
be a fantastic a way to sort of like
make a red Hulk without you know doing
the actual Red Hulk and I feel like uh
that's why like he was called Hulk Todd
in the um the early screeners before
they got that got rid of that so I
honestly feel like um we're gonna see a
hulked out version of Todd by the end of
this uh series I could I Bank on that I
also just was like when I was watching
it I was like what if they brought back
Liv Tyler They're bringing back
everybody
that would be so good I don't know how
she'd be like yeah I was his ex but like
she could also just be a scientist she
could just be a scientist and not an ex
she could just be a scientist and maybe
take turn into uh a Hulk but yeah Todd
seems more convincing I just want them
to bring back everyone from Incredible
Hulk to be honest you know what's
interesting is like after they did uh
the recasting with Ruffalo as Hulk that
seemed to be and I don't need to be
insulting Mark ruffalo's appearance
because I think he's a beautiful
beautiful man uh who you know Kelly and
I haven't discussed the terms of like uh
our our one your free pass the hall pass
our free pass uh I might I might use my
hall pass on Mark Ruffles
no it's not no it's not it's the best
way to use a pass
he's a wonderful man and he's got a good
heart he's a nice man who loves the
planet Jess come on and he loves the
planet come on are you crazy anyway I'm
a Ruffalo he seemed they seem to cast
him specifically because he has a very
pronounced jawline and when you're gonna
turn someone's face into a Hulk face it
helps that their face has a specific
structure to it and I feel like they
didn't really have that within Edward
Norton because the Hulk version of
Edward Norton didn't really look like
him whereas the Hulk version of Mark
Ruffalo kind of vaguely looks like
Ruffalo a little bit and that just
increased more and more especially with
smart Hulk by then it's just like oh big
green thick Ruffles
thick Ruffalo so do you like I'm trying
to think the actor they cast as Todd
like does he have that kind of facial
structure where it would make sense to
see him in Hulk form the thing is I
don't think we've been seeing the right
angles of Todd so yet yet because if
you've seen his head shot it's uh it's
like a a model like a Gucci model like
photo and I was like oh I don't see
these angles of him on the show and I
think we're just not hitting him like
we're keep hitting them straight on so
we see how round his face is we're not
really hitting him ever from the side so
I don't think we've actually this is how
much I look at actors faces oh my gosh I
know what you're talking about John bass
on IMDb he's like whoa he's like a smoke
show but he's otherwise he looks like a
comedic actor and sometimes these other
shots he's like a uh your college
roommate you know you know how our
headshots are a little you know like a
little judged up I get it but this one
I'm like this is completely different
I feel bad this feels like the kind of
like
I'm sure casting directors have this
conversation all the time in terms of
like an actor's facial structure but I
feel a little guilty no I think he looks
like it we just aren't seeing that angle
I don't think the DP has hit him on that
angle yet that we see in his head shot
that's on IMDb editors please put a
photo so we because we keep referencing
it and no one knows what we're talking
about but no he looks he's probably a
really really nice guy oh my God some of
his Instagram photos
wearing this is scraps it's a dog collar
that says straps Eric is on the
intelligence to your website
text it to me later I just think this
actor's really funny I thought it's
really great on The Newsroom when I saw
him on that show I like this guy they
watched I saw him on She-Hulk I found my
She-Hulk
so if you're making are you making us
choose between like whether we're gonna
see a Hulk modok or the leader at the I
guess you don't have to do too much of
VFX to the leader as much as you would
for a whole and um Modoc but like if you
have to choose between the three it'd
probably be like the leader right and we
wouldn't see a Hulk at the end in terms
of like what we're expecting to see in
the future I just think rather than
bringing in Tim Blake Nelson putting him
in new VFX setup or new makeup of some
kind I think it's more likely that they
have like an additional Hulk wannabe
character by the end of this show or
some people who are trying to make their
own Hulk uh and then that's kind of the
brawl at the end of it if it's Hulk is
in the title to me I think the move is
to have Hulk the finale that makes sense
yeah I feel like yeah at the very least
like this show is going to open the
doors for more hulks to appear in the
MCU because like I feel like we're gonna
get a bomb like we're gonna get Rick
Jones and like we're gonna get um
Amadeus Cho like we're gonna get more
helps so like very excited I hope this
series Ends by introducing Amadeus show
I mean that's like the character I want
to see like I don't need I know there's
like Hulk lean fans who really want to
see him in Young Avengers I think you
can accomplish that but just by having
an Amadeus show because Hulk lean is
like you know son of a scroll in a Cree
or something like that right I'm getting
it wrong but he's not like Hulk's kid no
he's not a wolf at all he's just he's
not even a Hulk he just they call him
hulkling yeah he's just green yo what do
you guys think about this idea of like
what if white vision is part of the
Intelligentsia that'd be a problem oh
that would be a major problem I already
told you guys and I got in trouble oh I
think it was in the break room where I
said white vision is gonna just end up
being like our God oh God
foreign
yes uh we'll see who's part of the
intelligencia hopefully by the end of
this series I'm very excited I love that
they introduced it uh there's a couple
more things we want to talk about this
episode let's quickly thank the people
who helped us make it whether you're a
superhuman Hulk or just a regular old
human we all want a comfortable night's
sleep in the best seats possible but how
do you determine which sheets are the
best with all those at confusing thread
counts that don't even matter at the end
of the day that's where Brooklyn comes
in Brooklyn and was created to give
customers luxury hotel level Home
Essentials they offer everything from
snuggly sheets to Cozy towels and robes
loungewear accessories and much more
they partner with top caliber suppliers
and use only the highest grade materials
Brooklyn knows better than anyone that
high quality materials are the most
important element of a good sheet not
thread count because each sheet is made
with ultra durable cotton that will get
softer and softer with every use in wash
you'll feel like you're snuggling up in
breathable Supreme Comfort every single
night no matter how you sleep and they
offer a top tier 365 day return policy
plus and additional year for sheets
pillowcases and duvet covers and if
you're new to the brand and not sure
where to start rest easy and shop and
comfort with Brook linen's online quiz
whether you're looking for the perfect
set of cozy sheets a new robe or a
complete home overhaul their quiz is the
best place to find a curated list of
high quality products perfectly suited
to your lifestyle so refresh and rest
today with Brooke linen Best in Class
betting go to brooklynn.com and use the
promo code inside Marvel to get 20 off
plus free shipping on your purchase of
100 or more that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com and enter promo
code inside Marvel for 20 off plus free
shipping on your purchase today we also
want to thank Helix sleep for sponsoring
this episode sleep is just so so
important and here at new rockstars We
Trust Helix to protect our sleep with
the best mattresses in the world I have
a helix mattress I know Mt you got one
too uh recently producer Zach producer
John have Helix mattresses Helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete and matches your body typing
or sleep preference this is the perfect
mattress for you everybody is unique and
Helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot matches great
for spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains and even the Helix plus
mattress or plus size sleepers producer
John took the Helix quiz and was matched
with the Helix dusk mattress because
he's a back sleeper that needed memory
foam to provide the perfect amount of
sleep to keep him sleeping through the
night because our baby boy John Princess
and the ped and the p is any little
rustle of wind that will wake him up so
we need something that will just put him
out and get him the memory recharges
that he needs to I don't know where I'm
going with it
I liked it though I dug it I like John
uh just go to helixsleep.com inside
Marvel take their two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free Helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com inside Marvel our next
question Mr Immortal let's talk about
this guy uh you mentioned that uh he
might have had some connection with the
eternals how is this guy alive for so
long it sounds like we got another Kingo
here do you think it could have crossed
paths with Kingo or any of the other
eternals God I hope so that'd be so much
fun because kingo's fun and he's fun and
like I just feel like they would have
some type of either like a history or
like maybe they like to have like a
competition or something like I feel
like there's some type of uh history
there because uh it's just be really fun
I guess it depends on like when he was
alive I I mean he clear at least from
the episode I'm assuming he was alive
during King Henry uh so it's like that's
old but is he older than before like
cavemen
yeah is he older than time like has he
always looked like uh Dave piscuasi at
his current age with with gray and hair
and the comics he doesn't age he looks
exactly the same so I guess he just came
out looking like that or maybe he was a
baby
he just stepped out put on his suit and
put in his little pocket square it's
like time to get married he's a time and
I said okay I said go off yeah I guess
you age to a certain spot and you stop
there could be also a backstory to him
stopping whether it's like death urge
was the reason why he stopped aging or
that he got hit by one too many cars and
stopped aging I feel like he had to have
come uh crossed kingo's path at the very
least because and we saw from eternals
Kingo has been an actor for Generations
so like that like he would see kid Go's
face like all right uh he was this guy
and he was that guy he was that guy that
guy can't die like me so he probably
just went to go visit him like hey how
did you get your not dying Powers sir
um because he was one of the few people
that actually notice can go is the same
guy I bet he noticed but he doesn't care
he gives off that Vibe that's just like
yeah I just don't want to even have this
conversation so I fake my death which is
a lot of work it's easier just to tell
someone you're done with them than to go
throw yourself in front of a car around
okay so we see the two type of people we
are empty and one of us needs to fix it
I hate confrontation
I'd rather die
yeah I think Mr Immortal is fascinating
because if you think about it the
eternals are just basically robots
they're synthetic weirdos who are
created by celestials just to caretaken
Earth whereas Mr Immortal in some ways
is the real deal we don't know how
really he has his powers but in the
comics like dirge is like you're gonna
be around after the universe expires
you'll never die which is just
fascinating I want this guy to have a
show he's kind of like weirdly important
and he needs his own kind of exploration
he's so sad in the comics he is the most
depressing character they could have
ever chose to redo for She-Hulk but his
story so that's why I'm like he would
make a great own series because it's
like the fun him versus the like coming
to terms with I'm Immortal for the rest
of my life and everyone I've Loved is
going to die and I'm going to witness it
so I would pay to watch this I just
think he's just a weirdo he's just a
weirdo he doesn't know how to place his
emotions in the correct spot and I love
him for it yeah a great casting I mean
I want him to leave the intelligence
I mean maybe entertaining I wonder if
they picked him because he's from Star
Wars or like already in like the Disney
Universe or because he's just a great
improviser because
all right we're now in the going into
the final three episodes right that was
the end of episode six and if you think
a nine episode season this kind of makes
her final Act of this season we know
Daredevil is coming and we know LeapFrog
is coming but I want to ask you guys
Beyond those two let's play some bets
who do we think are going who do we
think is going to be like the surprising
Cameo will there be any super surprising
Cameo and if it's not like a cameo like
a surprising character twist what are we
thinking for these for this finale I was
just gonna say leader as like the
obvious like very like I feel like
Leader's gonna show up the very last
scene like oh oh and it's me the leader
I'll be in Captain America four Tata
um type of deal uh goodbye
thanks for watching bye-bye so yeah I
think it's either the leader or Madman
um those two
um are gonna be the The Cameo but what
do you think Jess I I think it's gonna
be the exact same entrance last second
post credit scene and I think it's gonna
be Modoc uh I think it's got to be I
think it's got to be the leader of the
or Modoc because there's both of them
are coming up might as well introduce
them in some fashion especially since we
have the Intelligentsia so I'm Gonna
Leave Modoc I'm Gonna Leave Modoc here's
my theory I'm gonna just keep it
restrained because I think I've gone a
little off the deep end and uh past
Seasons that we've covered uh so here's
my theory I think the final battle of
the show is uh it's gonna be like a
version of Hulk but it's me like Hulk
Todd it's gonna be pretty restrained
pretty tame but then but then we're
gonna hear a voice from behind them and
say oh you're left and then portals will
open created by Wong and through one
portal will be William Hurt Thunderbolt
Ross they they kept his likeness and
they put it on a Hulk body and he's
gonna come in this Red Hulk and then
and then they're gonna have another hole
come in and it's gonna be Tony Stark's
Dead face like at the end of the end
game where it's just like that and it's
gonna be that auto body and it's gonna
be zombie hole and then every other Hulk
just more and more offensive they're
gonna have Queen Elizabeth II like this
on another British
and it's just gonna be one by one and
then we're gonna just be so enamored
with how far they went to offend us and
to outrage us that we'll have to stand
up and applaud you're like she-hole she
all did it they're they're only at
attacking the men they're only attacking
the men and they succeeded I think I
feel pretty good about my theory
um I think yeah I'm willing to put some
money on that one
the
the queen they knew they knew early in
the season or they just planned for this
just in case it did happen uh they
weren't really sure every show should I
think new girl did that too
unfortunately it ended before to quit
actually passed oh my god well everybody
what a blast it's been I love uh talk
about the show every week with you two
what a delight this is and Jess's Easter
egg breakdown is coming out tomorrow on
the channel uh along with mt you broke
down this week's episode of Rick and
Morty that will be on the channel
tomorrow too I did it was super fun and
super awkward so I can't wait
yes it was but I can't wait to see both
of those videos so everyone will be sure
to watch those and that is it for this
episode of inside Marvel follow Mt at
mastertainment follow Jessica Lulu
underscore Clements uh follow me at
eavos subscribe to inside Marvel
wherever you get your podcast subscribe
to new rosters here on YouTube and we
will see you next week but bye everybody
bye guys bye
thank you